pickup trucks are the biggest product
segment in the United States by far
Ford's F-series has been the top selling
vehicle line forever it was again last
year Americans love pickup trucks and so
this is one segment that Tesla does not
play in and uh Elon Musk has been
promising Tesla would come into the
pickup segment for a very long time a
few years ago the company unveiled the
Cyber truck and the expectation is this
is a new type of pickup truck that'll
address an enormous Market it's going to
be different than any other kind of
pickup we've seen before I would think
that the the truck will be core to their
business I mean if we as we've seen with
domestic automakers it is their bread
and butter and I think there could be
significant profits for Tesla with a
truck on the EV startup side rivien
clearly is a competitor because they
were out there first and they've got a
pickup truck and an SUV and then Ford
with the elect electric lightning and
they've got a lot of production capacity
that they're ramping up and they were
out there first as a real Mass marketer
and then of course you know GM will have
both the Chevy Silverado and the GMC
Sierra that will be competition as well
Elon said the vehicle would be priced
from about forty thousand dollars I
would say objectively that's a highly
unlikely price point for this vehicle
and in fact as it turns out over the
long history of Tesla there actually is
no Tesla product that's ever sold at the
base price that Elon has promised so
most people who are watching the space
assume that cyber truck is going to kick
off at a base sale price of around 70 to
80 thousand dollars again it's it's
still sort of unclear what we do know is
it's going to be heavy a few years ago
Tesla Engineers were communicating with
California's Department of Motor
Vehicles and they revealed that the
likely weight of the vehicle at a
minimum would be about 8 500 pounds and
to put that in perspective that's a
couple thousand pounds more than a
standard Ford F-150 cyber truck is
likely to be an extremely energy intense
vehicle to produce and and manufacture
and that's for a number of reasons it's
using this all sort of Steel and
aluminum body so there's a lot of metal
going into this vehicle the batteries
themselves are are large and very
resource intensive so lots of nickel
lots of cobalt lots of lithium coming
from all over the place if you look at
estimates by something like Argonne
National Laboratory which tries to
calculate the carbon intensity of
vehicles including how they're made
every EV sort of starts overweight in
terms of carbon emissions relative to
say a gasoline clean car it takes more
energy to build an EV because you have
to gather all these materials and the
manufacturing process is a little
different another kind of mild concern
or not maybe not so loud concern is
automotive tires vehicle tires wear down
over time and create dust there's a
chemical treatment on tires it's
designed to keep them from from wearing
out so fast but it turns out that that
particular chemical gets into waterways
rivers and sea and is very toxic for
certain types of salmon and maybe some
other fish heavier vehicles produce more
of this dust so there is an argument
that if you're putting an 8 500 pound
electric truck on the vehicle that
actually is going to be producing more
of this tire dust pollution than say a
conventional gasoline or diesel pickup
truck which may not be as heavy
analysts investors as well as customers
have been eagerly awaiting the release
of the Cyber truck production of which
has been delayed on a number of
occasions to date I think at this point
analysts are expecting that the Cyber
truck will be released at some point in
the first half of 2024 and they see that
as part of what will need to happen for
musk to achieve is very ambitious growth
targets which you know some view as
probably unachievable but you know
certainly important to making some
Headway towards those so I think you
know further delays or you know hiccups
as it relates to that release probably
you know wouldn't be good for the stock
there are a couple ways to look at it
there may be a group of buyers that
never would have considered a pickup
truck but because it's an EV because
it's a Tesla or a new one of the new EV
startups they will consider it I think
the other big question is will the core
truck buyers that are you know driven
F-150s and Silverados forever will they
uh shift to EVS I'm less certain about
that and then of course that that leads
to the question of what are the volumes
going to be and that's really hard to
know because we don't know exactly who
will be the buyers and and how many of
them there will be it's been a bumpy
ride for Tesla stock for sure it's Italy
East over the last year or so you know
dating back to Mid April of last year
when Elon first announced his Twitter
acquisition through the end of the year
the stock crashed by nearly 70 percent
before rebounding recently the
distraction of the Twitter acquisition
to Elon and all the stock that he had to
sell to finance it put a big role in a
significant decline in Tesla's stock you
know most of elon's net worth is derived
from his shares of Tesla and his options
to buy shares in Tesla largely by driven
by the Twitter acquisition the decline
in uh Tesla stock over the last year or
so has taken Elon who a year ago was the
richest person in the world by nearly 50
billion dollars seen him replaced by
Bernard or no of lvmh as the world's
richest person
foreign
the company when it introduced itself to
the world in 2006 set this really
aggressive agenda that we're going to
change Transportation with sustainable
Vehicles powered primarily by solar
power so they really wanted to be
associated with clean energy clean
transportation from the very beginning
but he also said something important
which was the first vehicle was going to
be an expensive one the Roadster but
each subsequent vehicle would cost less
and less and less as the company scaled
up and got better at making EVS well
we're pretty deep into things now it's
about 17 years in fact since the first
roadsters were built those cost about a
hundred thousand dollars the average
Tesla today retails for about sixty five
thousand dollars
I would argue that objectively the way
Tesla products are now positioned it's
harder and harder to make the argument
that this is purely an environmentally
oriented purchase from the very
beginning the company knew what it had
to do to get people to buy these things
to take EV seriously they had to be nice
to look at and fun to drive and they had
to have features that were as good as or
Superior to those in a gasoline engine
car and they did a terrific job with
that what they didn't do was then keep
working to make them more affordable and
actually more environmentally friendly
for more people